[Music]
it's June just after a heavy rainfall
and the sky is filling with creatures we
wouldn't normally expect to find there
at first glance this might be a
disturbing sight but for the lucky males
and females of Solenopsis Invicta
otherwise known as fire ants it's a day
of romance this is the nuptial flight
when thousands of reproduction capable
male and female ants called a laits take
wing for the first and last time but
even for successful males who managed to
avoid winget predators this mating
frenzy will prove lethal and for a
successfully mated female her work is
only beginning having secured a lifetime
supply of sperm from her departed mate
our new queen must now single-handedly
start an entire colony descending to the
ground she searches for a suitable spot
to build her nest ideally she can find
somewhere with loose easy to dig soil
like farmland already disturbed by human
activity once she finds the perfect spot
she breaks off her wings creating the
stubs that establish her royal status
then she starts digging a descending
tunnel ending in a chamber here the
Queen begins laying her eggs about 10
per day and the first larvae hatch
within a week over the next three weeks
the new Queen relies on a separate batch
of unfertilized eggs to nourish both
herself and her brood losing half her
body weight in the process thankfully
after about 20 days these larvae grow
into the first generation of workers
ready to forage for food and sustain
their shrunken Queen her daughters will
have to work quickly though returning
their mother to good health is urgent
in the surrounding area dozens of
neighbouring Queens are building their
own ant armies these colonies have
peacefully coexisted so far but once
workers appear
a phenomenon known as brood raiding
begins workers from nests up to several
meters away begin to steal offspring
from our queen our colony retaliates but
new waves of Raiders from even further
away overwhelm the workers within hours
the Raiders have taken our Queens entire
brood supply to the largest nearby nest
and the Queens surviving daughters
abandon her chasing her last chance of
survival the Queen follows the raiding
trail to the winning nest she fends off
other losing Queens and the defending
nests workers fighting her way to the
top of the brood pile her daughter's
help their mothers succeed where other
Queens fail defeating the reigning
monarch and usurping the brood pile
eventually all the remaining challengers
fail until only one Queen and one brood
pile remains now presiding over several
hundred workers in the neighborhood's
largest nest our victorious Queen begins
aiding her colony in its primary goal
reproduction for the next several years
the colony only produces sterile workers
but once their population exceeds about
23,000 it changes course from now on
every spring the colony will produce
fertile ale-8 males and females the
colony spawns these larger ants
throughout the early summer and returns
to worker production in the fall after
heavy rainfalls these a lates take to
the skies and spread their Queens genes
up to a couple hundred metres downwind
but to contribute to this annual mating
frenzy the colony must continue to
thrive as a one massive super organism
every day younger ants feed the Queen
and tend to the brood while older
workers forage for food and defend the
nest when intruders strike these older
Warriors fend them off using poisonous
venom after rain falls the colony comes
together using the wet dirt to expand
their nest and when a disastrous flood
drowns their home
sister's band together into a massive
living raft carrying their queen to
safety but no matter how resilient the
life of a colony must come to an end
after about eight years our queen runs
out of sperm and can no longer replace
dying workers the nests population
dwindles and eventually they're taken
over by a neighboring colony our Queens
reign is over
but her genetic legacy lives on the US
honeybee population has been decreasing
at an alarming and unprecedented rate
why are all the honeybees vanishing
watch this lesson to learn more
[Music]